[Music]
thank you for joining us America Robert
is employ C Idaho hey Robert how are you
how's it going just the same sir not
gonna help okay so here's my situation I
called in for some advice for like the
next two to four years ish and my
situation I just graduated college I'm
22 years old and I start my job next
week making seventy one thousand dollars
base pay and I'm nineteen thousand
dollars in my own personal student loan
debt and then my parents took out
additional loans in their name totaling
about another nineteen thousand no other
day no credit cards or anything like
that we have a value my wife and I have
about twelve thousand in savings and my
wife also she's looking for a job as
well as she'll probably be making
between thirty and forty thousand so
we're trying to I'm trying to figure out
what my best course of action is going
forward we also want to find a house in
the next like twelve to twenty-four
months on trying to figure out if all is
available okay are you responsible for
your parents lunch I'm not I'm not
responsible no but I feel kind of like
an obligation to help them pay for
because you know their finances aren't
in the best order and you know me
getting this decent job right out of
college I feel like you know I'm
responsible for that that want the money
as well did you have an agreement with
them one way or the other what was that
did you have an agreement with them one
way or the other no agreement I what
does your parents make a year it's a
basically a single income house I'm
guessing about sixty thousand okay yeah
they have they have other expenses and
debt as well so mm-hmm the well if you
want to give your parents twenty
thousand dollars as a gift which is what
you're just got discussing here I would
do that after you meet some of your
basic financial goals
okay but that is not your debt well I
don't okay so um but if you want to give
them a gift and help them out at some
point in your finances that's fine but I
think you've got some basic things you
need to hit first and that is you need
to clean up the existing debt that you
two have hopefully with a hundred
thousand plus income you can pay that
off and use the savings that's there you
can pay that off very very quickly right
I I'm trying to pay that off I'm in the
grace period so I'm trying to pay that
off before my first payment so I think
your interest Ryan well you said you had
how much in savings twelve thousand
roughly I mean I have some impact events
but like that kind of investments too
you know well just like about I'd like
two thousand dollars in stocks is it in
an IRA no okay cash that out and put it
on the student loan today and take your
twelve thousand down to one thousand and
put that on the student loan today and
then you'll be debt-free in about two
months then you brought your emergency
fund was that the only debt you had did
I miss something there's another no
we've we've been very fortunate
I bought a car very cheap from my aunt
and then my mother-in-law gifted my wife
her car okay so you don't have any other
debt other than your nineteen thousand
well yes no I have a balance on my
credit card right now just because we
moved here but I'm getting on I've got
in a movie and incentive from my
employer so about that will be paid off
as soon as I get that mm-hmm okay but
you can pay it off too and then when
you're at your money back you could just
put the money in the bank all right so
all right the thing here is this you you
have to get your head around the idea
that having no debt is the shortest path
to wealth and so every time something
comes up we move here my credit Mike I'm
gonna use a credit card my employers
going to bring birch me though that's
not okay okay you have to stop that kind
of stuff and every time you get rid of
buy something you have to pay cash for
it mister point forward completely
avoiding debt it is your big deal here
so I want you to clean up the credit
card I want you to clean up your 19,000
wasn't there some
you told me other than their parents 19
doesn't hear it something else your wife
had something no other don't know just
that no she doesn't have any that either
I mean she doesn't have anything I think
I said that um she's looking for a job
yeah that's somewhere between 30 and 40
okay I guess I'm slipping okay anyway so
I want you to clear up the credit card I
want you to clear up your student loan
using your income your $2,000 stock
account and eleven thousand of your
twelve thousand thrown at these things
immediately and cut up the credit card
and get a debit card then I want you to
finish paying off your student loan
because you can't quite do it with that
and as fast as you can and then as soon
as you do that I want you to build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then and only then do you
start saving towards a house you'll be
able to buy a house in about a year when
you guys get into the house and you have
your emergency fund in place into zero
debt and you've put a good down payment
on the house and you have a house
payment that is no more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed then
before you start investing if you want
to start and reach over and pay off your
dad's loans that's fine at that point is
when you would do that kind of family
type of giving but but I want you to get
into your house and be debt-free and
have your emergency fund in place and so
probably year after next before you pay
off dad's loans but that's cool if you
want to do that no problems but they're
not your loans and so I would put them
in a different place it's charity it's
giving it's generosity and and that's a
good thing for you to do all that but
you put that in a different place in
your in your process here so that's how
I would get after it hey thanks for the
call